with the predator now out on wide
release digitally and on blu-ray and DVD
lots of hidden info about the film is
being released through its special
features and cast interviews throughout
this video I'll be breaking down the
movie's original ending as well as the
deleted Ellen Ripley cameo that's meant
to feature in it there will be heavy
spoilers here in regards to the final
cut so if you don't want to know
anything about the movies ending and
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I ruin it so you don't
have to it's pretty well known that the
predator went through extensive reshoots
that completely changed its third act at
the test audiences didn't enjoy the film
the original ending of the movie focused
more on gene splicing and had the
Predators teaming up with the humans in
order to take down the upgrades and
hybrids the original plot can be seen
throughout the movie and feels like
random mentions of things that end up
underdeveloped in the movies final cut
the ending reveals a predator killer
suit that pops out of a pod found on the
predator ship however this pod was
originally meant to open and showcase
none other than Ellen Ripley in
incubation she is in weyland-yutani
overalls and one of the developers on
the film stated that we shot three
different endings for the predator all
variations over predator killer his
unused ending was predator killer Ripley
wearing the breather mask we created for
the film you can see her name tag on her
costume Briana Watkins played Ripley
under the mask instead of Sigourney
Weaver's however the moving fingers and
tails were deemed to face hug alike on
the day and will cut and remove by
someone this would obviously have ended
the film on a huge cliffhanger even if
it makes a little sense the original
alien was set in 2122 whereas this film
is 2018 but i'm sure they would have
explained it all away with time travel
or some other guy out of jail free card
there were also rumors that Arnold
Schwarzenegger was going to appear in
the film but the star rightfully turned
down the cameo appearance which would
have shown him leading Earth's troops to
the predator planet so what do you think
of the original ending of the predator
you prefer it to the Iron Man suit we
got and how do you think that they would
have explained Ellen Ripley's appearance
comment below and let me know and
you enjoy this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of the
original ending for bird box which will
be linked at the end this is a channel
for people who were mad into movies so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace